go impress - parapa and welcome to
Scribblenauts unmasked if you rose
watching play Scribblenauts unlimited
you know more or less how it works the
main character Maxwell has a magic
notebook that he can write anything into
and it will summon it and that's used as
a game play to solve puzzles which is a
really awesome gameplay I kind of missed
it to be honest so yeah there really
Scribblenauts unmasked which is
basically more or less the same thing a
bit improved along with the DC comic
universe which seems pretty interesting
so let's check it out Gotham City a city
under siege although how they kept the
Batman
sound check this contract better pay out
owes awesome go instead that am i doing
the hell is she doin Lilly Lilly Lilly
stop sleeping hold on Lilly I'm coming
I'm gonna get ya
yes skin is ooh scoop up a bit I bet let
me just skip my way through there press
to attack okay
touch ah of course poof um but use your
notebook I need a doctor
she needs a doctor
dr. dear dear James what the hell did oh
wow
that isn't even made dr. James what a
what a bad person she needs a doctor
let's get her a doctor
there you go what are you doing knocked
over here
there you go grab the object okay oh not
him uh I can't do a man what do you want
do you want from me Oh Oh Batman you
think you can run around chasing chaos
causing chaos
nobody might eighty all she did was
getting sick how dare you get sick we're
good guys just like you someone matching
this description has been seen as
assisting the choking Oh Batman someone
who can take who can make anything
appear out of thin air I don't take no
Jason oh man
what Billy kids I'm headed for fame a
count a pack so quick that shot is the
world's deadliest assassins here's your
notebook to modify Batman with an
adjective
oh this is great okay he's a slob that's
not helping him I don't I don't know
what rich how would that I don't know
you're younger okay um super buff super
beef beef super yeah of course
you're welcome Batman you're welcome got
away for now you did just save me tell
me all your names I maxima and then my
trance is Lily
Lily doesn't even respond this is yours
what is it that's my glove at Slava's
travel whatever you want it but it's
broken and my dad totally gonna turn me
to stone again what a mean dad come on
Maxwell place the kaffir of cars lately
so can I have an okay silly fangirls
they just never know when to stop okay
let's make our self sassy flying sassy
works how did he become more sassy I'm
so curious now oh wait let's take the
elevator okay take him to Arkham as a
limb so we need to something oh he has a
lot of scars geez how about a plastic
surgeon No okay this should work right
okay you're coming with me mister
I don't care what up with my change okay
here we go
you're coming with me mister like it or
not
oh no he's escaping go khatola go make
me press no oh khatola beats everything
kill him kill him khatola we need
something else
it looks like Cthulhu is moonwalking I
like it okay how about a giant lasers
sword yes go khatola nothing will stop
you now nothing what I want your goddamn
problem gold unique what the hell are
you doing good solo come on man you
can't do that I don't know what you're
doing
I know they killed my unicorn really
really really what my kid Cthulhu kill
him I'm hitting with a hammer
what okay
I thought Cthulhu would do a better job
than me but I guess not
you are now in your own exposed Gotham
and help those in need
we'll turn this city back to its safe
place but first we shall turn you into
fabulous oh my god you're fabulous
kaathal oh love it
all right time to solve okay wait what
what just happened what is going on I
don't think this supposed to happen
get off ha ha ha ha ha four fours okay
alright let's just living those aside
let's do a story mission with the Joker
oh no it's it why are you happy
it's his evil twin ah all alone huh not
exactly
oh my god it's Batman Joker Oh
Maxo I could hold off the Joker you do
anything that double gang me how about
he deals with this what he's crazy
a giant robot dinosaure got nothing on a
giant robot fabulous rainbows no I don't
want to do it just a rainbow what do you
know and robots that way I wanted at all
you got nothing on my duck no one can
stop the fabulous duck except that oh no
no all right let's show those where
weeds made of take this yay
that's that's all you got out no not my
dog why do you have to attack my dog Oh
rest in peace rainbow duck give my man a
weapon okay
giant Lego Batman give him he'll
what what's wrong with my tentacle I
ninja sword you go madman there you go
there you go doppelganger why don't you
teach all pointy ease here have a chill
out no no we got this all right Dada
Dada Dada Dada yeah are you boys ready
for it
what that's not that's not that's cool
to do that at someone told me
we're in metropoliz okay that's cool I
like it's super my fangirls they're
everywhere
maxvill is knit but digging the music
it's an honor to meet you
oh man I'm so jelly right now Mac Bell
we'll meet soon enough lately what how
did you hear me super hearing of course
now young man Padma tells me huh
what's happening what's happening
Maxwell huh
it's middle school in the fifth
dimension troublemaker look how the hell
they plan that Scoob stink no fill
valves that's pretty impressive what
people can't pronounce my name oh thanks
ha ha ha ha lesson kiddo
I've been here a lot of people talking
about how impress your power of
imagination is how they that's great
well they're wrong my imagination is
obviously far superior to yours and to
prove it pencil boy
sometimes when you teleport really get
you going to spice things up a bit we
can go to different areas now ok well I
kind of want to be here so yeah go doc
we shall save the day in a year because
of them you're slow duck there we go
he walks yeah
I think you can spit fire now whoa
best duck ever holy cow
sorry nobody always kill my dogs my
vehicle was broken
well not too broken and neon broken
you're welcome I mean fix yeah genius
Vince where's my duck my sight I swear
to God my sidekick is the worst it's
like what the hell do you say I need a
medical tooth stack well that it is
there you go whoa I didn't think that
would work
why don't be kuma chicken oh well
starving Chinese food crescents button
so hungry
well you can have my duck that didn't
wait this is for eating my other doc
that's what you get let's go in here I
have no one left a sad orphan appeared a
doc mom I'm sorry I'm sorry
hey you got let's pretend that didn't
happen
alright let's do another challenge all
right I'm gonna have to end the first
episode here but if you've always wanted
me to play more let me know the gameplay
in this game is just like the most fun
you know that I tried in a long time
forcing a play would be fun if this game
had multiplayer I think that would be
very interesting anyway let me know what
you think brother hit subscribe to come
to earth today a few brothers in the
next one
stay awesome
whoa can you see that
I love the music I love everything I got
I got